tu est clair c'est net c'est précis je
l'écris demandant figaro il regretté
emmanuel macron à une chance
extraordinaire c'est que dans son pull
dans sa stratégie pour sa réélection
françois hollande s'est planté d'un an
c'est à dire que ce qui arrive fin 2017
il pensait que ça arriverait fin 2016 et
donc lui permettrait de pouvoir se
représenter à sa propre succession
sauf que il ya eu l'année 2014 qui a été
complètement pourri économiquement et
qu'à tout décalé d'un an ce qui fait ce
qui devait se passer en 2015 s'est
produit en 2014 ce qui devait se passer
en 2016 c'est prenant en 2015 ce qui
devait se passer maintenant là en 2017
c'est à dire avec 3 une croissance qui
est supérieur à 2% en tendance annuelle
avec près de 300000 emplois créés en
glissement annuel avec un taux de
chômage qui est en baisse ce à cette
situation économique la devait se
produire fin 2016 et fin 2016
l'association a pas été du tout la même
politiquement pour françois hollande
auréolé de ce bilan la contrairement à
celui qu'il avait apporté son sac à dos
avec plein de pierres dans le dos il ya
un an
ils ont qui lui aurait permis de se
présenter donc oui aujourd'hui emmanuel
macron bénéficie d'un souffle d'erding
blast économies que engendrés par son
prédécesseur et également grâce à une
croissance mondiale qui est reparti en
croissance et atik qui se tient bien
mais sur les fondamentaux économiques
nationaux c'est le pacte de
responsabilité
c'est le pacte 500000 formation pour les
chômeurs qui produit même faiblement ses
effets donc tout ça fait que aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron bénéficient des fruits
récolte les fruits de son prédécesseur